so you're at coachella dude yeah man do
you remember anything from coachella
yeah when was that yeah
the irony about three years ago yeah the
irony that you were at a liquid iv party
and you still couldn't cure your
hangover
oh no that [ __ ] actually worked i did it
i had about five okay when i was at that
party all right good because i i came
prepared
what if i just pulled out a big middle
finger
we i we brought you something oh thank
you yeah
liquid iv
no no
i'm still in marketing mode dude i don't
know what to do yeah clearly
clearly he can't ultimately hydration
multiplier
this is not sponsored by liquid iv look
at this guy although can i tell you can
i just name drop a little bit yeah just
dump it out i feel like you know you get
back from coachella and so you got to
talk about who the celebs you saw
celebs you rub shoulders with yeah well
okay so we were joking last week about
sweet sweet sweet scene
the classic line yeah
and i still thought i still thought this
is so funny and i have this stupid idea
for a tick tock
so i busted open ableton
and edited his song so that the sweet
semen line just replayed just looped
yeah back to back to back yeah and then
i took i filmed myself and took it into
premiere it's the most effort i've ever
spent on a [ __ ] tick tock nice like
all well like this is at the house that
we were staying at yeah we got there and
i just go into the lab and i'm just
they're like what is he doing cooking
they're all like coming by the pool and
i'm like just on the computer like this
just sweet sweet human sweet demon
he's cooking up a talk yeah exactly he's
making a tick tock oh yeah and so i
finally finished this [ __ ] and i'm like
ah could be funnier but whatever i'll
post it
because i still think the like the idea
is funny right right so i posted it and
in my head i'm like i hope he doesn't
see this
yeah
because we are kind of like we know him
you know yeah well we know his crew
yeah and we're friends with his the guys
that he hangs out with and i met him one
time and he was super nice and we took a
picture together and uh this was like
right as he was blowing up like this was
like right after the cole bennett video
came out yeah and so he wasn't like he
is now yeah in terms of fame yep but uh
he was really cordial super nice and i
felt like we were friends right so i was
like i hope he doesn't see this i hope
it doesn't like i don't know get
offended by it and he's like what the
[ __ ] this guy was nice to me and now
he's making [ __ ] on me on tick tock
what the [ __ ] yeah i didn't want that to
happen right
i thought it was a pretty innocent joke
so i posted it and uh i go to this
liquid iv thing which was he was playing
at yeah and i was like no chance i'm
gonna see him there's gonna be a big ass
crowd and whatever
and uh
we wanted to do this stupid bit because
i had to post a tech talk for this brand
deal thing so i would want to do this
stupid bit where one of the security
guards like
frisks me and i have a whole bunch of
liquid iv in my pocket or something and
we asked this guy and he's like no
he's like no i'm working and we're like
i know
stupid question yeah
and he was he was waiting outside the
sprinter van and as as i'm like
sheepishly walking back like why the
[ __ ] did i ask that security guard
i just look up and jack's right beside
me walking up the walkway together with
his security guard
and
i look at him and i'm like oh what's up
dude and i dab him up and he's like yo
i saw that sweet semen video by the way
i was like
no you really you did and he was like
yeah and i was like
sorry he's like i thought it was funny
and i was like okay good
anyways how do you and then you just
okay yeah
cool
just gonna go [ __ ] myself yeah
no i thought it was funny yeah that's
that's exactly what he did
that is exactly what he did he was nice
about it
i didn't know if he actually thought it
was funny that's probably the best you
could you could hope for yeah yeah
it was funny
in milwaukee this weekend i
someone made a comment about it at the
end of the show and i just started
saying the line
and
sure enough a lot of women in the room
just start yeah i was surprised
the room just starts chaining along
and then i laughed and i was like yeah
yeah yeah don't [ __ ] act like you
weren't leaving comments and tweeting
like oh my god this line is so stupid
well you guys like it look at you love
you i was like i said the first suite
and then you guys just sweet i just
jumped into it so i'm like i don't want
to hear at least from the people in this
room that you thought that [ __ ] was
corny i mean i like i asked last week i
want to see like who else thinks this
line is corny and i didn't get as many
comments as i thought like people were
like we even got some opposites that
were like no i gotta be honest that line
like really turned me on yes i was like
what yes and then i saw a clip of him at
a show
doing the song yeah and he does a beat
break he has the dj turn off the music
at that part and the whole crowd goes
sweet sweet sweet semen yeah i'm like
and he does this as a dance move he goes
yeah i swear to god like i cannot
believe everyone in the front row opens
their mouths yeah they come with trash
bags yeah and they punch each other he
has a bottom milk yeah
and he sprays it out into the yeah yeah
no he doesn't do that they catch it but
he does do this i swear to god they
catch it in the trash bag they fight
over who's gonna take the sweet sweet
semen yeah
damn okay so that was one okay
part of the reason why you go to
coachella is to see all the celebs yeah
yeah i love celebrities yeah
and my but potentially my favorite
mm-hmm
was mr logan paul
yeah it was actually so funny what did
logang have to say
honestly i was like kind of cause like
we went into this area and all of a
sudden jeff was like yo he like reached
out and he's like yo what's up and and i
was like hey man and i stopped and then
i like looked to the right hey he's with
mr love just him and logan yeah and i
was like oh no no what's gonna happen
here he actually punched you
yeah i just did what his brother didn't
yeah
no he was really nice actually i
he was really nice no
he said uh
he kelsey was there too he's like i
really like what you guys got going on i
love your relationship or something and
then i was like oh thank you and he was
like no problem
and i was walking away and jeff was like
hey
at least it wasn't jake and i was like
yeah that's true i guess
cool
[Laughter]
and then um
what a politician
yeah what a politician i i i like i have
no i don't have a mean thing to say
because it was just no he was really
cordial no i say that in in like um
that is someone who's made so much
[ __ ] money he can't be helped
like to be petty
okay yeah this is not worth it to him
that's what i'm saying yeah yeah
i'm sure i'm sure he's being genuine
yeah it's just uh he's just at that
level yeah where it's like you're
kissing babies and you're shaking hands
and
she's like hey love what you got going
on you guys are great yeah i watch you
without a single feeling of malice
because my life is awesome
see you and i'm so much more rich than
you yeah
yeah so it's like why would i even stoop
so low as to dislike you anymore uh i
sparred floyd mayweather which i've yet
to be paid for but that's okay because
i'm paid in a lot of other avenues so
every month i drop an nft project yeah
and i make
your family's net worth
in a day yeah
and when i say family i mean you're like
entire deadline yes of course that's
your lineage yeah all the money that
your entire family name has made across
your whole life uh adjusted for
inflation of course i make that in
roughly 30 seconds
so why would i hate you i feel bad for
you yeah
oh my god
are you wearing one day old shoes
yikes
hey man it's gonna get better where's
your security guard yeah
oh i don't have one
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna punch an
unprotected man
that's just
that's just low
[Laughter]
shoot him please